okay meanwhile there is a big piece of
election news coming out of the supreme
court the supreme court john roberts is
just a terrible justice he is i'm sorry
he you know his he thinks that his sole
mandate is to somehow
preserve in some way the the legitimacy
of the court and his
way of preserving the legitimate
legitimacy of the court is to avoid
quote-unquote controversy in the here
and now as opposed to controversy in the
later
he's constantly kicking the can down the
road so on the aca he will rewrite the
law
just as just so that the supreme court
is not required to strike down
a law that was very controversial he'll
rewrite it just to quote unquote
re-establish the institutional
legitimacy of the supreme court question
did it help answer no
john roberts is constantly doing this
kind of stuff so here's a perfect case
in point
yesterday the supreme court refused to
take up
a case split 4-4 on taking up a case
on pennsylvania voting so here's the
underlying fact pattern
in pennsylvania there is a law on the
books the law on the books is that you
have to vote by november 3rd
right november 3rd is not an arbitrary
deadline as andrew mccarthy points out
it is the election it's a date fixed by
congress for voting across the country
to take place okay well under the
constitution
states have a great deal of discretion
regarding the manner in which elections
are conducted
but that discretion is not limitless the
election is november 3rd whatever time
frame the states allow for early voting
whatever procedures they prescribe
for authenticating legitimate mail and
ballots the voting has to be concluded
on november 3rd
the constitution states it is for
congress to determine the time of
choosing the electors
in modern parliaments for conducting in
each state the presidential election
the states don't have authority to alter
that date okay in pennsylvania they just
altered the date
the pennsylvania supreme court says andy
mccarthy from national review is
enmeshed in politics its members are
elected not appointed for 10-year terms
a few weeks back in a 4-3 ruling along
partisan lines with democrats in the
majority
the court nullified the mandate duly
enacted by the state's legislature that
mail-in ballots
must be received in the office of the
county board of elections no later than
eight o'clock pm
on the day of the primary or election
you know that that
law makes perfect sense right because
what you would like to do is start
counting
so everything has to be received by a
certain date this is something by the
way that the post office actually warned
about months ago they put out an actual
notice to states across the country
saying you know guys you really should
change your laws
so the final date on which people can
send their mail for an election gives
enough time for us to deliver that mail
such that the thing can be received by
the date of the election
the constitution and federal law as the
supreme court has observed vests
discretion to set election rules in the
state legislatures not state courts
and as even the pennsylvania court
conceded it was within the legitimate
power of the state's general assembly to
set this deadline
there was no ambiguity about it or any
legal infirmity right
if you wanted your ballot counted it had
to be received by november 3rd
yet the court's democratic judges
dictated a three-day extension
of the lawful deadline for counting
mail-in ballots the vehicle for this act
of willful usurpation was a lawsuit
brought by surprise the pennsylvania
democratic party
the state court's majority invoked a
hurl at the wall and see what stick's
combination of rationales
said to flow from covet national natural
disasters emergency situations
a loopy construction of the state
constitution's free and equal elections
clause
theorizing that since the virus does not
affect all people the same way
provisions the legislature makes to deal
with it
somehow render elections unfair and
unequal
so what does this actually do what does
the court ruling do the court
effectively ruled
that you can vote after election day the
pennsylvania court requires election
officials to presume
that any ballot received by its extended
deadline now november 6th
must be counted even if it lacks
postmarked proof it was mailed on or
before november 3rd
so you could see an election in which
the entire thing comes down to
pennsylvania in fact this is quite easy
to see because pennsylvania's a
battleground state
right you could see an election in which
trump replicates all the states that he
won except for
michigan and wisconsin and now he needs
to win pennsylvania and joe biden needs
to win pennsylvania and the entire
election rests on pennsylvania
and it's november 3rd and we don't know
the results right november 3rd
happens and it's a very tight election
in pennsylvania again right now
that election is within three to four
points right it's close to margin of
error
and you now have a pennsylvania law that
says that
if no the day after the election right
november 4th now
everybody looks at the tv they recognize
it comes down to pennsylvania
and everybody rushes to their mailbox
and sends in their ballot people who
didn't vote they rushed to their mailbox
and now they send in their ballot
according to pennsylvania state supreme
court those will be counted if received
by november 6 whether or not they are
postmarked late
even if it lacks postmark proof it was
mailed on or before november 3rd
as andy mccarthy said in effect the
green lights voting after election day
even as the national media is reporting
the results of a contest that is
supposed to be over
for those reasons the state's republican
party asked the supreme court to stay
the court's ruling to the extent it
permits voting after election day
the supreme court adheres to a so-called
purcell principle arising
out of its 2006 ruling in purcell versus
gonzalez that courts must not change the
rules for an election late in the game
purcell is now being flouted not just in
pennsylvania in wisconsin judge william
conley an obama appointee on the federal
district court
presumed to rewrite a number of state
law election related deadlines including
extending the deadline for
counting absentee ballots until november
9th in his wisdom judge conley
caveat of the ballots should only be
counted if they are mailed in by
election day november 3rd which sounds
fine in theory
but there's going to be a lot of dispute
about when ballots were mailed right
you're going to say i dropped it off
at the post office i dropped it in the
mailbox november 3rd it wasn't
postmarked until november 4th
so did i mail it in on time so the
supreme court
could have intervened here the supreme
court could have done something here
okay well in april the high court
intervened in a similar wisconsin case
judge conley hadn't just extended by a
week after election day the deadline for
mail and ballots to be received
by state election officials he had
ordered that votes be counted even if
they were mailed after election day and
the supreme court
stayed conley's order all four liberal
block justice including
now deceased rbg dissented from the
unsigned opinion by a five justice
majority
the majority concluded that to permit
people to keep voting after election day
would gravely affect the integrity of
the election process
but the opinion took pain to emphasize
it was forbidding the counting of
post-election mail-in ballots because
conley had ordered it unilaterally
i either had been no request for that
relief which suggested if a party had
asked for the court might have approved
post-election day voting
which is insane so now the court is
is essentially saying that they are
going to put off decisions on whether or
not to count ballots until after
election day itself
so here's how this is going to go let's
say that it does come down to what we're
talking about it comes down to
pennsylvania
it comes down to states that have
extended their voting deadlines after
election day
which is crazy by the way and now you
have a ninth justice on the supreme
court amy coney barrett who's going to
be confirmed this week or early next
and now democrats proclaim that a
five-seat majority on the supreme court
with amy coney barrett in the majority
is illegitimate because amy coney
barrett was rammed through
i mean the possibilities here are
devastating and if you're talking about
the legitimacy of the supreme court
if that's john roberts's chief concern i
cannot think of anything more calibrated
to undermine that legitimacy than what
the supreme court is doing
right here facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content